vince velasquez he's made some
adjustments as he's gotten older let's
see if he is able to utilize those
adjustments today 40 stolen bases last
year
caught nine times
that was close
oh yeah he's not he wasn't even on the
base he is out at first
glory two for eight in this road trip
one two pitch
and a fastball strike three calls 94 on
the gun back to back strikeouts for
velasquez yesterday reece walked three
times and scored a run
that falls pole down the left field line
toward the corner hooking it is a one
hop off the wall it's in for an extra
base hit bobbled by dickerson police
have runners on second and third bryce
had a fun hit yesterday
that one that's good missile deep to
right field it is gone
look out on the stairwell a three-run
home run for bryce first of the year
29th against the marlins and the
phillies jump out to a 3-0 lead bruce
played game one he was over four
out to left center field on the run is
sierra toward the corner it's off the
top of the wall into the middle of
center field backed up well segura is
going to score bruce to third the throw
not in time it'll be an rbi triple it's
four nothing
hey sue sagittar
will lead off
here's a swing and a
high drive to deep right center field
harper going back so is hazley looking
up and that ball is gone
jesus aguilar with a
towering home run and the marlins right
away get one back it's four to one
runners on the corners one out rojas off
to a good start these first couple of
days
sends one in the air to deep left field
back goes bruce and it carries out for a
three-run home run for miguel rojas and
it's a 4-4 game
right between the legs of cervelli the
throw to third goes past anderson into
foul territory the phillies will take
the lead miguel rojas who armored his
last time up a three-run shot that tied
the game at four
and now the 1-0 pitch is hit the other
way right field gonna get down another
multi-hit game for miggy road it gets
stuck under the wall a little bit diaz
rounding third throw from harper well
off the mark and rojas having himself an
afternoon it's 5-5
and now the high chopper and it gets
over a drawn in infield
and sierra heads towards second and with
that speed will get there easily
six to five marlins in rbi for
sierra brian anderson was hit by a pitch
score to run in the second
mba hits a high fly ball down the right
field line's got a chance and it is up
up and away in a home run for brian
anderson to the opposite field so brian
hits his first of the year a good day's
work for the marlins they lead this one
nine to five
and corey dickerson with a high drive oh
man what a blast to right field
corey dickerson with a home run
his first as a marlin is a moon shot
and he absolutely demolished it
paisley singled his first time at bat
doubled his second time up
that one's out to left field dickerson
going back toward the fence and he jumps
and it's off the wall and he kicks it
toward the corner
rounding third heading for ole miss
gosselin
and he's going to score it'll be an rbi
for haisley and the phillies are now
back within fours the bases are loaded
and it'll bring up d.d gregorius
out to center field and right at sierra
the side is recovered three run homer in
the second an rbi triple in the fourth
and a single back in the fifth inning
needs a two bagger for the first
cycle in marlins history
2-2 pitch oh man up and in he's up
quickly fortunately shaking that right
hand which would be that top hand on the
bat
yeah you hope the finger is all right
for rojas who clearly staying in the
game
and now sierra laces one of the gap in
right center field that is going to get
down and this could easily be three for
him rojas will score sierra chugging
toward third he will get there standing
up it's 11-6 well now hoskins who has
walked each of his last three plate
appearances today
hoskins rips it anderson makes the catch
and it's a marlins win
so they do what they wanted to do go to
philadelphia where they've played well
get out of town with a series win and
get this season off on the right foot